Speaker 1: All right.
Let's go now from Nikki Haley, who is officially
running in 2024 to Ron DeSantis, who is not
officially running in 2024.
This is super interesting.
Fox News interviewed Ron DeSantis this morning
and said, hey, what do you think about all
of these Republicans that are attacking you
now?
The main Republican who has been attacking
Ron DeSantis is Donald Trump.
No mention of it on Fox News.
Just they don't even mention it.
What exactly is going on here?
I have an idea and I will tell you in a moment.
But let's take a look at this clip.
And again, when you see how every day Trump
is attacking DeSantis, how do you interview
DeSantis about all of the people that are
attacking him and not mention the main guy
who's doing it?
Look at this.
You've come under.
Speaker 4: A lot of incoming fire recently.
Nikki Haley taking aim at you.
Larry Hogan as well, the governor of Illinois.
You know, from your visit coming up here to
Chicago, Twitter.
What's your reaction to some of those attacks?
Speaker 1: Okay.
So it's already weird because, like, who's
paying attention to Larry Hogan's attacks?
Everybody's paying attention to Trump's attacks.
Speaker 5: Well, Lisa, you know, if you're
if you're an office holder and you're just
sitting there twiddling your thumbs and not
getting anything done, no one ever says anything,
you can kind of just fly under the radar.
But when you're out there leading, when you're
out there setting the agenda, not just for
Florida, but really for the nation, which
we've.
Speaker 1: Done, he's setting the agenda for
the nation.
This does sound like a guy who's running.
Speaker 5: Over the last few years, people
see that.
And the people that they don't necessarily
like that are going to respond accordingly.
But I can just tell you, if people are not
firing at me, then I must not be doing my
job.
And so I view it really as positive feedback.
Well, listen, you could get some positive
feedback if you just stood up, turned around
and said, Hey, folks, I'm going to run for
president.
Just saying you would wind up in a standing
ovation right now.
We'll give you 20 seconds.
You guys like to have have that announcement.
I mean, it would be.
Speaker 1: So, listen, we are going to delve
into this in a lot of different ways.
But what is FOX News doing here?
How does FOX News, which has been softly leaning
towards DeSantis and softly getting ready
to get away from Trump if Trump is not the
nominee, why don't they bring up that?
The lion's share of those attacks have been
coming from Donald Trump, that that's who
people are paying attention to, and we'll
have examples of it later on in today's show.
Not Larry Hogan and Nikki Haley.
Nobody really cares about those attacks on
DeSantis.
Well, it seems that it's part of the same
strategy we've seen, which is Fox would rather
someone other than Trump.
But if it is Trump, they don't want to openly
be hostile to him.
Now, Trump has already started targeting Fox
to some degree, talking about sinking ratings
and different things, but it seems part of
that same strategy.
Fox isn't ready to abandon Trump yet, but
they do want to set themselves up to be friendly
with whoever.
And so the way is you bring on DeSantis, you
ask him about the attacks on him.
You just don't mention that Trump is one of
the people that's been attacking him.
They're creating fake.
It's the there's constantly an elephant in
the room that people aren't mentioning.
And this is the latest example of it.
It's going to be a wild primary, that's for
sure.
All of the clips I played for you in this
segment you can find on our YouTube channel
at YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show
and on our Instagram, just search David Pakman
show on Instagram.